well joining me now is former World
chess champion and chairman of the
renewed democracy initiative Gary
Kasparov Ukrainian ambassador to the UK
vardham price sticker I'm sorry I
sneaker former head of the British army
Lord dannett plus russia-born author and
podcaster Constantine kitten okay well a
great panel first of all uh Gary Castro
let me stop and thank you for being in
the studio I greatly appreciate it
what's going on
you're a chess Grandmaster can you work
out what's at play here as a cheers
Grandmaster I'm used to analyze facts
and I believe what we saw was a tip on
iceberg is so much still underwater I
don't think Pringles acted alone I think
that was a much bigger challenge to
Putin's Power by those in Russia uh
mostly Gru or KGB who were not happy
with the world Ukraine don't forget
Russia is a mafia State and there's so
much money is at stake and Putin
basically is a liability for those who
have been doing this business with
hundreds of billions of dollars maybe we
should look for answers for pre-order
operation in Africa I mean we don't know
enough but what we know is that Putin's
regime looked at the facing first real
challenge as a Hollywood decoration just
big decorations nothing behind it so
Putin made a big statement you showed
the statement nine nine a.m it's it's in
the morning who followed his orders
nobody
what was the government nowhere to be
seen Parliament Senate a Ministry of
inferior Minister of Defense their own
gun so it's just you know it's it's a
colossal song on on Clay feed and I
think what we saw was just the First Act
of the drama uh uh I would don't trust
you know the stories about these deals
because again I think this so much is
behind behind the scene and it was all
about I believe commercial interest but
what is important is the way pregosian
troops were received by Russians I think
it's more more about corruption because
the the name of the pregos operation was
March for justice and I think that's
this is the people instinctly
demonstrated it's uh that's the this
corruption regime uh uh this puts his
regime as as no support as it claimed
the whole story of Putin was popular has
been just you know destroyed by by the
March which stopped for no clear reasons
preggers could be could have taken
mostly in the next 12 hours but none of
it really makes a lot of sense General
done we just been told the Rochester
State media reporting that Vladimir
Putin will make a series of important
announcements this evening that'll be
his first appearance since denouncing
the Wagner Mutiny what's he gonna say
what what do you think is going on here
well be interesting to see what he is
going to say because on Saturday morning
and he had a lot of words but he didn't
have much substance at all and looked
like a man pretty much caught in the
headlights so unless he's reinvented
himself something clever I think we're
going to see more more of the same
I think whichever way you look at it he
is now a weakened man and what
pragosians extraordinary sort of March
for justice towards Moscow showed was
that Putin's got very little support
where was his army an Army in an armed a
mutiny situation like where were they
can do one of two things it can oppose
the mutineers or it can do nothing they
chose to do nothing right and this
actually speaks volumes even the uh is
it the beginning of the end of Putin
historically with Russia when this thing
happens this kind of March if you like
or assault on whoever's running the
country tends to be the the end pretty
quickly
um I think it's very much related also
to what is going on in the battlefield
in eastern Ukraine and I think that's an
extraordinary set of circumstances the
counter-offensive which has been talked
about for a long time well-equipped
well-trained well prepared
um a lot of preliminary operations have
been going on there will come a point at
a point in time and space I don't know
where or when when the Ukrainian forces
feel they've found some weak spots and
that's when they'll press with their
attack brigades and then Anything Could
Happen how diminished militarily are the
Russians in Ukraine right now without
the Wagner group well they are
diminished because the 25 000 also
fighters that were fighting they were
fighting side by side with them in
Bachman until they've withdrawn so
numerically the Russians are are weaker
also the senior Commander control from
General grazimov down that's now got
question marks over it how much
Authority can he actually deploy and
then of course you come to the Russian
soldiers themselves most of them don't
really want to be there right they're
poorly equipped poorly trained very
poorly LED at low level yes they've got
wonderful defensive positions but if
they can if those defensive positions
can be cracked into then frankly
Anything Could Happen literally anything
in order to get overly optimistic and
lives are involved here Ukrainian lives
are involved here well although possible
they could break through and be very
successful yes I agree uh Ambassador
brustako I mean I can't even imagine
what your weekend was like I was gripped
to this literally watching cable news
the entire weekend
what were you doing
same I was wasting two days of my time
on weekend quietly I think just to
understand what is actually happening
how it can influence what is happening
in our part well I can tell you that for
us both of them is a precaution or Putin
both of them are enemies we understand
that the the wind is fighting it will is
a situation in our case at least this 25
000 people or six more helicopters will
now appear in Ukrainian Skies so that's
what we were hoping what was interesting
also it was not very well reflected that
what precaution said before starting he
went and making I'm just interrupting
your invested one moment we now have
live
pictures of Vladimir Putin he's actually
talking yet we're going to keep an eye
on this this will be an interesting
statement it's it's come actually uh the
Press service for the Belarusian
President Alexander lukashenko has
written on telegram a lot of questions
stuffing versions and assumptions the
first one will tell everything answer
everything very soon follow the agenda
again some cryptic messaging coming out
of Belarus there
what do you make of that I hope that
we'll talk now about the minister of
defense or a chief of defense and if it
is the part of the sort of the agreement
with preggers
remember he went to Moscow saying that
he is going to undermine the particular
two individuals not the Putin himself so
he was living certain flexibility here
but having Luka shanken picture they can
talk now about the even glow sort of
deeper unification between Belarus and
Russia they might tell it's so volatile
of of course on the face of it my first
thought was this looks good for Ukraine
that in just as you're launching a
counter-offensive you have the Russians
in total chaos of course knowing the
character of Putin it could be the
reverse he might decide to double down
in Ukraine to go even harder more
aggressively that's a potential right I
agree I agree with it was Gary that
there are some circles in Russia which
will be more interested some of them are
not happy with what is happening it
doesn't mean that it won't go
unescalative and higher and the
oligarchs nothing can be done in Russia
without alligatory consent so what they
want what they want to you know to get
rid of sanctions or they wanted to
finish it up right now right away so
let's escalate let's finish it up
whatever the consequences let me bring
in Constantine guessing Constantine
you've been tweeting away about this the
last three days fascinating actually to
get your take on this how are you seeing
things as we well we're watching
Vladimir Putin about to make some
addressing what he's going to say but
what's your take on it well some very
good points have been made so far the
one thing I would add is I think uh
people haven't emphasized enough the
fact that anybody who's going to attempt
to replace Vladimir Putin is likely to
be more nationalistic and more Hardline
than uh him at the moment as you know
over the last quarter of a century
Vladimir Putin has removed everybody
who's attempted to challenge him uh from
a more liberal or more Democratic
position and one of those men is sitting
to your left
um Gary Casper of course and uh so what
I think people forgot in the west is
there's no Nick Clegg waiting in the
wings to take over this is a very
serious situation this is a nuclear
Nation uh with the potential for civil
war so I wouldn't get too excited about
it even though of course we would all
want to see uh Russia less powerful in
its uh terrible invasion of Ukraine so I
think that's one of the things to add
and the thing that is happening right
now on our screens is Vladimir Putin
giving a statement I imagine we will see
him attempting to reassert Authority
because what we have seen over the last
many days is that his Authority
certainly in question yeah I'm not sure
Gary you've been shaking your head this
I'll come it's absolute nonsense I mean
it's total misunderstanding of the
nature of any dictatorship after 23
years Putin is a spine of the system you
cannot take spine away and put someone
in the place whoever comes after Putin
will start negotiating with Americans
with ukrainians there's no no doubt
about it it's that's what happened after
Stalin's death so you cannot have
another dictator of basic Putin because
he's the center of the series making
process and now it seems that he's no
longer Capital he's not a final referee
in all all these negotiations between
various groups so that's why it's like
you know saying oh shaufenberg also
brought some questionable people with
him and after Hitler who could have
somebody worse no absolutely not but if
you take your mafia analogy for
argument's sake in the mafia if the head
boss got taken out they would replace
him with often somebody even worse it
takes time before before you have
somebody else they have to negotiate
it's more like a politburo which always
better because they have to enjoy what
do you really think in your bones is
going to happen here Gary oh I think
it's this it's these this growing
opposition to Putin's to Putin because
he's losing the war there's a huge
commercial interest that is not
interested in to continue unwillable War
they know this war cannot be won and
again what will be the outcome of this
fight I don't know but I don't even put
it will stay for too long because if
Russia history is any guide the bad
words always led to the change of the
regime ambassador
what does Victory look like here is
there any potential as some people have
called for Ukraine to cede any of the
territory that the Russians have taken
or is your position still implacable you
do not give them an inch
that is a position that we are not going
to give an inch to anybody and Russians
the first and second I'd like to say
what about Crimea for example which was
taken years ago for me as well you'd
like to see that I'd like myself that's
true and by the way we already started
to liberate some of the places which we
are under occupation since 2014. not
just a recently acquired lens so that
that's that's what we are already doing
did you feel total Victory is now very
achievable in fact potentially a lot
more achievable than it looked last week
much better now that's true this jar was
the with the spiders in it you know who
will get out of it will be wounded and
will be weakened totally agree and if
you want to you're talking about the
analogy historical analogies if you
remember when garbage got back after the
coup it only took four months until the
whole system collapsed afterwards we've
got this some some uh quotes now from
Putin tonight General Janet I'll bring
this to you the organizers of this
Rebellion he says cannot but understand
they will be brought to Justice everyone
understands this that is Criminal see
that is aimed at weakening the country
from outside we are threatened however
the organizers of this Rebellion have
betrayed those people who were bribed
into this organization so he's saying
apparently also the society has
Consolidated so much evidence of that
but he's he's suggesting from that
unless I'm misreading it that the Wagner
group have betrayed Russia and they have
to be dealt with but there's no sign
from the vulgar group that they're
fearing not going to happen well he said
that on Saturday morning that these
people were brought to Justice by
Saturday evening he said that they would
um be allowed to go their way so he's
now reverting to his first speak
um what do you believe what do you
understand I mean I think um
he's lashing out I think he's showing
further signs of weakness by holding
completely differing points of view is
he done Putin do you think I think he's
done and go back to what I said before I
think when the Ukrainian Army's
counter-attack uh really gets going then
I think he will be completely done and I
think the big point of the battlefield
to remember is that if they do manage if
the Ukraine has managed to break in and
break through they haven't got to defeat
the Russian army everywhere they've just
got to make the average Russian soldier
think he's lost and when an army thinks
it's lost it's lost and that's what
they've got to try and Achieve and they
can do that some more quotes here
Constantine I'll bring you in here a
Putin most of Wagner are also Patriots
he closed his speech by saying president
Erica shenko obviously the Belarusian
President should be thanked for his role
in this to achieve a peaceful resolution
it's a patriotic duty of everyone that
has saved us thank you so some kind of
mixed messaging although I guess what
he's uh trying to say tonight is that
the Young organizers are the culpable
ones uh what does that mean though
what's he gonna do well as I said as I
predicted he was going to attempt to
reassert Authority but on the other hand
he doesn't want to make enemies of 25
000 of his most capable soldiers uh who
are quite loyal to again in precaution
as far as we know but I think there was
a misunderstanding about the previous
point that I made I wasn't suggesting
that uh a coup would make Putin stronger
what I was saying was that a lot of the
resistance to uh to the regime at the
moment isn't actually focused on
Vladimir Putin a lot of the criticism is
of his defense minister shoigu and the
head of the Armed Forces girasimov and
that I think is where this has all come
from this conflict has been brewing for
many months now with a war of words
between pregosian and the ministry of
defense and so what I I was saying and I
think this is important to say the
liberal Democratic voices like Gary have
been forced out of Russia and so much of
the resistance to Vladimir Putin isn't
people who want uh democracy and
stability it's people who feel that the
war is going badly as he says and they
want someone to come in and take charge
so we it remains to be seen how this one
actually plays out yeah apparently just
reading some reports on Twitter here
that apparently he said the uprising was
doomed to fail and his organizers even
though they lost their sense of right
and wrong couldn't have failed to
realize that he also seemed to say that
Ukraine was involved somehow and calls
the Revolt revenge for their failed
counter-offensive he then ranted about
Wagner's treason a bit more and then it
cut out he didn't actually announce
anything so someone on Twitter here uh
Gary what do you mean of that
mad rentings yes it's just I think he
lost control and probably feels that is
this uh he can keep talking but nothing
is happening and uh what you just said
now just doesn't make any sense no none
of it makes sense no do you think he'll
still be in charge in a month's time
months maybe
um definitely not within a year probably
you know three to six months Ambassador
what do you think it will be bloody it
will be dirty but he's going down
General and there might be a churn
someone might replace him and then
someone might replace that person I
think the second replacement could be
more favorable to the west and just the
final Point general what message does
all this send to China who may have been
considering attacking Taiwan is this a
marker in the sand that if you do this
kind of thing as a dictatorship that
actually can backfire pretty pretty
horrendously the Chinese should think
very carefully about taking on the world
over Taiwan actually the Chinese were
patient people just give it time
um they would be most unwise to take any
lessons out of this if there is a lesson
actually it's a coup such as
such as Putin tried to mount on Kiev
24th of February last year it did not
work so just don't go there General
Ambassador Grandmaster great to see you
all thank you great panel tonight
Constantine thank you as well for
joining me much appreciated a lot going
on in Russia a lot going on in Ukraine
going to be fascinating a few days and
months to see how this all plays out